hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday March 21st 2016 what's going on
how are you this wonderful gloomy Monday
where I'm at gloomy out here chance of
[ __ ] shower which would be great you
know because how it works out here in
Los Angeles is we basically every three
years we get all of our rain for three
years essentially that is how it works
and I know a lot of people think like oh
my god that must be so wonderful you
know you just wake up every day knowing
that Suns gonna shine it [ __ ] drives
you crazy after a while fortunately I
travel enough I get on the road again
boom boom boom boom meeting Trump fans
and some voting for that old guy what is
it with the [ __ ] Bernie Sanders you want
to take all the money in from the
[ __ ] rich and give it to the poor and
Donald Trump he doesn't like make a camp
and Hillary is going to drive right
between those two [ __ ] lunatics
ah good lord jesus [ __ ] christ
I haven't been watching but I know that
that's what's going to happen and all
you broads out there who are [ __ ]
excited to finally get a [ __ ] clam
into the [ __ ] Oval Office okay just I
understand I don't understand I'm not a
[ __ ] woman I don't know what it's
like to walk by a construction site and
have a bunch of people communicate that
they find me sexually attractive you
know you know there is a positive way to
look at that if you take away all the
sexual assult vibe from it it's kind of
a you know a nice tip of the
construction cat you know I don't walk
by and I go you find him on the [ __ ] I
get not I get nothing I get you silence
I get Snickers hey [ __ ] caspo right I
may make fun of my lack of melih the
melatonin I'm pigment melatonin isn't
that [ __ ] I forget that the fruit and
that's not the skin cancer don't you
need melatonin oh Jesus who gives a [ __ ]
I'm just saying right just because
somebody has a vagina doesn't mean
because you also have a vagina
that they are going to do what's right
for you think about all the presidents
that have had dicks which as far as I
know has been all of them but you never
know you never know you never know back
in the day there were no cell phone
pictures right there was no video
cameras you had no idea you know I you
know Andrew Jackson and he could have
been like you know he looked like one of
those broads on [ __ ] the [ __ ] at a
man that showed the Golden Girls he
looked like one of the Golden Girls sort
of their hip her younger one you know he
really had that middle of the ground you
know that is it a chick is a dude Roger
Daltrey early eighties haircut you know
except it was a powdered wig over there
yeah I mean I'm just saying just because
somebody has the same [ __ ] thing as
you does not mean that they're going to
do what's good for you or that you're
now going to get more stuff like look
she's in the White House
doesn't that mean I get a corner office
no it doesn't [ __ ] do you have to do
with her I got to admit yeah if I see a
red that achieved something I don't feel
excited like us only a matter of time
before that comes around my way and I
know what you think you know what we'll
build it's not like redheads or a
minority yes we are an unseen minority I
told you walking amongst you listening
in on your conversation reading your
emails we're here man what some another
foot from [ __ ] Maas the Red Planet
that's where we came from we came here
right we look just like you guys but
then we [ __ ] up when we entered the
atmosphere right we got a little [ __ ]
singed up there
and burned our pubes oh my god the
[ __ ] gloomy day it is a good goddamn
gloomy day I hope the [ __ ] the
goddamn clouds part anyways old our old
freckles he's looking for a new car
I'm looking for a new car baby a new car
and I got to admit I actually feel like
I'm
uh you know like leaving the Prius
behind you know I've had it I had almost
eight years with the thing runs like a
[ __ ] top I don't know I just want to
get something new I got a buddy you
might buy it I don't know I'm a frugal
son of a [ __ ] I'm probably just going
to go look but you know it's a good a
good time to look for a [ __ ] car is
on a rainy day you know all those
[ __ ] toolshed
[ __ ] salesmen they are the worst the
cars fit cars Mayo salesmen are the
lowest of the low of [ __ ] salespeople
and you know what's funny they know it
they wouldn't even lie about it they
know what the [ __ ] they do I mean
they're like one rung below a drug
dealer at least with drugs you know you
get some sort of a high well I guess
when you buy a car you do you know I
don't [ __ ] they are just like Anna
the great thing is is I'd really don't
need a car so I'm in a great negotiating
negotiable negotiator goshala position I
was going to go and be like yeah I like
that and this is what I'm going to pay
and so go discuss it with your manager
and come back and come back with that
number or something less or I'm just
going to get my car you trading that in
nope I can sell it to my buddy or I can
just drive across the street not take on
all this [ __ ] debt just go get myself
a ham sandwich huh what do you say this
stupid tie go talk to your manager I
always talk a good game and then I go in
there and I get [ __ ] because at the
end of the day I just I don't want to be
there and it's just I don't give a [ __ ]
if it cost me a few grand more it's like
how much more do I have to pay to get
you to shut the [ __ ] up and they know it
you know what I mean you know women talk
about how guys just wear them down
sometimes and they just just sort of
blow them to shut them up and just get
them on their way that's what car
salesmen do to me now they don't blow me
they they just thought they do wear me
down though they [ __ ] wear me down
and I'm just like oh you know I okay I
remember when I bought my Prius I was
just like I went in I said listen I'm
paying this and that's it and I go well
we're not giving you for that it's a hot
car we
like three a day like well then I'm
leaving and then they go alright and
then I went all right I'll pay what you
want me to I am the [ __ ] worst
I want all you salesmen to note that a
sucker just went through the dough
that's going to be meeting about [ __ ]
two hours all right what the hell am i
what am i talking oh you know what I'm
actually really enjoying I actually had
a cigar I told you for the first time
and I got to admit I kind of didn't I
liked it I liked it in it but there was
way more I don't like this shitty taste
in my [ __ ] mouth the next day then
there was that I enjoyed that and I am
on the precipice of just straight up
quitting those [ __ ] things which
should make me feel really good to be
honest with you like I said if I keep
smoking these things this summer I'm a
four year smoker something I never
thought I'd be now I'm not going to
start crying right now like some broad
they just won an award pretending to be
a nurse on you know some [ __ ] show
you like me you really like me I don't I
don't need that [ __ ] in my life although
I gotta admit I do enjoy do I enjoy them
I think I remember that I enjoyed the
last one I had I like I liked it but I
didn't afterwards I was like blah Jesus
Christ his [ __ ] taste in my mouth so
did you guys consider me a smoker if I
smoked one New Year's Day the Superbowl
my birthday and then on one of those
Jewish holidays in September I needed I
needed for thinking like once every
three months what the [ __ ] cake my
birthday's June so I come out of the
gate right boom January first I smoked
one and then February 3rd is the
Superbowl and then it's nothing in March
nothing in April nothing in May and then
in June for my birthday BAM I smoke one
and then I don't know maybe that big
college game I go to every year you know
I don't know I have no idea I think you
know so I remember what the [ __ ] I was
going to tell you guys when most
last time there was something I wanted
to tell you but I couldn't remember what
it was I tried to make no key the other
night did I tell you that yo key however
the [ __ ] you say what a goddamn [ __ ]
disaster
[ __ ] disaster you know what this base
it just tasted like you know just
imagine what cookie dough would taste
like - everything that makes it taste
good
it was just blob of [ __ ] blobs of flour
what happened was when truth I was a one
on the Internet and I was watching these
[ __ ] chefs make this [ __ ] and what
they do is when they go to mix it they
fast-forward through it or they just
jump cut because they feel that it is
boring and that no one's going to watch
the rest of it and that right there
that's the key right there it's like
they open the playbook and then they
just go they fan through every [ __ ]
page and then they like and that's the
game plan for this they were going to
run this season any questions on two on
two ready break right you like what I
what the [ __ ] just happened so I believe
they got me so [ __ ] paranoid i watch
this Mario Batali one where he had his
friend do it and you know he's got he's
going to show you how to make no key you
you just look up so look at Mario Batali
[ __ ] blah blah you're super thing big
they fly through him mixing the [ __ ] and
but the big thing that kept saying was
don't overmix it don't overmix it you're
going to get a tough pasta yadda yadda
yadda yadda yadda yadda knowledge [ __ ]
and these [ __ ] [ __ ] they just so
they blew right through it and then i
under mexican i got an outsider feel
like I already told you this one I told
you this right and he said you should
make pasta anymore you know there you go
there's my supportive wife I swear to
God do you ever wonder why the woman
that loves you is always [ __ ] on
everything that you do you know not
everything you do but anything new you
try they [ __ ] [ __ ] all over you you
know what I think that is I think that
that there's some sort of [ __ ]
paranoia within a relationship maybe
guys do it - I
I never dated a guy you know you know I
think I'm going to try this bummer
[Music]
you guys still like me if I dated a guy
for like three [ __ ] months you know
what if I dated like my doppelganger I'm
trying to get the most [ __ ] up image
you could possibly say to me I'll date
that guy from [ __ ] uh we're all wacky
in the house over here whatever the [ __ ]
the name of that show is you know oh
look at you you're you're [ __ ] I'm
from Malaysia look at me
I like show tunes hey I'm the old school
guy from [ __ ] the Korean War right am
i describing my cartoon I can't remember
anyway um the [ __ ] was I just talking
about ah goddamnit my [ __ ] brain just
goes in one straight line and you just
got to keep going I keep going if I come
back around again it's just like I don't
even know where the [ __ ] I was at back
up back up was before dating a guy for
three months but it was after gloomy
lonely [ __ ] weather so after the car
crooked car salesman
come on bill you coming around the money
come around the mouth we going up and
down Lou remember that Mary Tyler Moore
won when Lou Grant had a great [ __ ]
idea and he came he just forgot about it
man I had the best idea and Mary Tyler
Moore is trying to get him to remember
she goes okay okay you're in the
elevator you're in the ability coming up
two Colombians going yeah yeah yeah any
elevator she was yeah you know you
created you press the for you coming up
you're in the elevator and you would
think any right as he almost gets it Ted
Baxter just leans in he goes where
you're going up or down low oh speaking
of that [ __ ] you know what I watched the
other day I watched an episode of
Gilligan's Island
the ones that were in black and white
instead of watching March Madness
because I don't like the first couple
around I know there's all those upsets
but I don't like watching [ __ ] Bunker
Hill Community College playing Duke I
know every once in a while they get beat
and I guess there was a bunch of [ __ ]
upsets you know I know that one [ __ ]
that that that Austin Austin City Limits
College with that [ __ ] I couldn't
tell through the lumberjack or a hipster
that [ __ ] jacked white dude with the
psycho beard man in the Hitler Youth
haircut I was like that guy needs
one more win and they fell to other team
[ __ ] tipped it in and they lost right
at the [ __ ] buzzer but I was thinking
that guy needs to get to one more round
and he is going to be he's going to be
famous you know I just seem that cuz I
was looking like I I remember who he is
and I assumed if I remember then
everybody else is going to remember
because you know why wouldn't the whole
world think the way I think
well [ __ ] maybe I should run for
president I think when you have thoughts
like that that means that you're
designed to be a world leader I have
great ideas and I think everybody why
wouldn't everybody like my ideas and
everybody should think the way I think
and everybody will be good if I'm
running stuff you know and everybody
will get the same amount of stuff except
I'll get a little bit more and buy a
little bit more I mean a bunch of hos a
bunch of dough's it's something else
about my toes um well you know what I
can't remember what the [ __ ] I was
talking about I did start talking about
basketball but you know someday actually
having a little bit of much madness the
madness of March is coming down to
Anaheim and I heard the Duke guys the
Duke boys Panther Board we come right
back man on down down we're a wanker
looking up coming to Anaheim at the
Honda yeah I think I'm going to go to
that you know who's getting who I got a
two huge [ __ ] shows coming up this
weekend one in River side and the other
one at the Paris theater in Long Beach
California which is really no big deal
it's just a beautiful theater that
Richard Pryor takes its first big
special in that's all I'll just be
standing on the same stage no reason to
prepare or be nervous for that one I'm
freaking out about that one I'm not
gonna lie to you guys I just feel like
I'm already putting all this pressure on
myself but if I don't have the [ __ ]
my show of shows that I don't know the
comedy God's gonna be like it
it is these comedians nowadays you know
they're also on a bunch of [ __ ]
tickets but then they they stink then
that's the real deal
but anyways I'm thinking it by if I go
out tonight tomorrow and Wednesday right
to a couple two three okay and then
Thursday right I hit the Duke game then
on [ __ ] Friday got my show and
Saturday got my show and just not goes
out I feel like I'll be alright I feel
like I can take one [ __ ] day off you
know am i nuts my nuts because I didn't
last night this is the thing I stopped
smoking cigars so you know what happens
when you quit a bad habit something else
[ __ ] goes through the goddamn roof
you know what I mean it's like to be
quit smoking you start eating right you
stop boozing you start shooting smack
right you say I'm going to start
cleaning up around the house next thing
you know you're beating your wife and
you know why it's because nobody is
perfect you ever go to a [ __ ] a
meeting they're all in their [ __ ]
chain-smoking and [ __ ] shoving Donuts
down their throat they're still killing
themselves they just slid it over to
something else that's basically the most
fascinating people I find is the people
that are just 100% straight edge and
they eat like a microbe macrobiotic
microbial whatever the [ __ ] it is
macrobiotic diet is a macro you say
macro I say micro beep Adama do poo um
those [ __ ] people but you know what
it is and they don't do anything ok they
[ __ ] you know they drink [ __ ] you
know pure the most purified [ __ ]
water out of a unicorn horn or some [ __ ]
right it's the most the most [ __ ]
cleanest living ever but you know what
they probably kill themselves with the
stress of knowing they're still going to
die you know how how do you think you
treat yourself when you really think
about it I think I treat myself like I
wouldn't say the way I treat a rental
car I treat around car pretty good I
don't beat the [ __ ] out of it when I was
younger I used to
it was just funny to give you a car and
you just you know remember neutral drops
for some reason we're considered [ __ ]
amazing you know you just have it in
park
you would know you put a neutral bagel
bill neutral drop and you would just
floor it get the RPMs up to but oh I
don't know seven eight thousand and then
you would just slam it into [ __ ] drive
and you just heard that horrific sound
of I don't know what the [ __ ] it is on
an automatic Trish transmission you know
with the standard to be the clutch it
and that's [ __ ] engaging and whatever
the [ __ ] engages it on a [ __ ] know
basically gears slamming into other
gears I can't believe the teeth just
don't fly off on both sides
I imagine eventually they do but we
should do [ __ ] like that you know you
take the car off road you could do a lot
of [ __ ] back in the day before everybody
had a [ __ ] camera you know oh speaking
of which I going to tell you what I
[ __ ] thought oh my god I almost
forgot to tell you this [ __ ] story and
we do a little advertising here first oh
look at that little teaser remind me to
talk about the [ __ ] local [ __ ]
wine thing I went on with my wife
mother-in-law and my brother-in-law
alright where the [ __ ] is he advertising
here for this week if you knew Suzy like
I knew Suzy oh oh what a gal she loved
it I just kind of calling her a [ __ ]
off you knew where the way I knew her
you mean you [ __ ] her
alright me andhis me undies drying out
your [ __ ] clams me undies me undies
the butchers name was [ __ ] Sam he was
banging Alice and her clam was dry he
thought he was doing his job he didn't
know why she had the first pair of
[ __ ] me undies that was 1968 so they
broke up if you ask me I thought she
went down a different road I mean she
was a lesbian
alright me undies Oh
whether you're wearing a suit or swept
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your
underwear
unless you're an animal or Matthew
McConaughey right but instead of making
a statement like Superman's tights under
his clothes every day your underwear is
probably boring the undies is here to
change that please include the following
I'm going to it's pronounced modal every
pair of me undies is made from success
from sustainably sourced modal a fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton now can
somebody tell me where the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] came from this is this is from a
lab you know I mean please tell me
there's not a group of people that are
forced to go out to the field and pick
modal you know God knows there's going
to be some great music that comes out of
that one
nothing can disrupt the fit and feel of
me undies me undies drying out you a
ball bag but once you try them on you'll
understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear
underwear yeah yeah yeah and if you
don't love your first pair of me undies
they're free no questions asked
I don't understand that why would you
keep a pair of because you can't give
them back you know you can't have you
dried up [ __ ] genitals sweat in those
in the undercarriage of those things you
can't resell those sure you can't you
put them on the internet for those
[ __ ] people they like to sniff other
people's underwear what is with those
people they a dog in their past life
what the [ __ ] is wrong with a bit that
noses are cold the perverts have cold
noses anyways my undies has dozens of
style and limited edition prints to help
you make a statement with your underwear
whether anyone can see them or not
remember Superman
okay shipping in the u.s. is in Canada
is free and you can save up to eight
dollars a pair with me undies
subscription plan get the subscription
or a single pair get 20% off your first
order when you go to me undies comm
slash birth subscription Jesus Christ
how much Tony how much you [ __ ] your
pants every month you got ever
description dude I bought [ __ ]
underwear I can't even like and I just
wear that [ __ ] til it's over you know
what I mean I wear my underwear until it
all I got is just a band going around my
waist looking like Chris Gatlin anyways
get the subscription blah blah blah
that's me undies com / / for 20% off
your first order the undies dot-com / /
alright tracker might as my phone might
home technology has made everything
smarter wick oh my god he's a wicked
[ __ ] tonight but losing your stuff
still makes my people feels really
stupid I don't think it doesn't think it
just makes them frustrated I think you
just wrote that because it sounded good
with the copy it don't let's just read
the rest of it all right track or makes
losing things a thing of the past
tracker is a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bags
computers drug paraphernalia whatever
you're always leaving around the house I
can't seem to find anything in seconds
do you beat your children with the
wooden spoon do they try and hide it you
won't lose it anymore
you'll be able to beat their ass in a
second because tracker will help you
find that blunt object just pair a
tracker to your smartphone attach it to
anything find its precise location with
the tap of a button it's that easy lose
your phone press the button or tracker
and your smart phone rings even when
it's on silent you know I just realized
somebody's going to kill this spouse
with a blunt object in the house and
then they're going to take it and
they're going to throw it in the river
but they're going to forget that device
is on it and the cops are going to use
it and then they're instantly going to
be in the Hall of Fame of world's
dumbest criminals
with over 1.5 million devices tracker
has the largest crowd GPS network in the
world so your lost item shows up on a
map even if it's miles away you'll never
have to use your brain again never lose
anything again with tracker listen to
this listen uh listeners to this show
Jesus get a special discount of 40% off
your
first tracker device go to the tracker
th e TR AC ke R dot-com and enter promo
code BRR
Bravo uniform Romeo Romeo the hardest
thing you'll ever had to ever have to
find is their website snicker snicker
snort go just go to the tracker calm
right now enter the promo code bar for
the 40% off again that's tracker comm
promo code bar alright and lastly but
certainly not least Lee dance comm
mailing and shipping are a routine part
of your business of running your
business important keeps your operation
went mailing and shipping are a routine
part of your business important comma
keeps your operation going
dot dot dot but I feel like this should
be way more dramatic at the way the
writing is important
keeps your business going your business
operations going but if you're making
constant trips to the post office that's
a routine you need to change there's a
much more convenient way to do it you
tell your wife to get up or fat [ __ ]
ass and get no stamps calm calm brings
all the service of the post office right
to your desk by imprint official US
postage using your own computer and
Preta print postage for any letter any
package any class of mail so you can
focus on what really matters getting
shit-faced during the day growing your
business I use stamps calm any time I
send out any my posters right now you
can sign up to Stan's calm and use my
last name BIR for this special offer for
week trial plus one hundred one hundred
ten dollar bonus offer that includes
postage and a digital scale don't wait
go to stamps calm before you do anything
else you click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage not the bottom at
the top and you type in Furby you are
are that stamps calm and Ripper alright
okay so you guys ready for this little
[ __ ] Safari thing you know it's doing
real good with my [ __ ] posture now
I'm sitting on my lower back again I
need to sit up sit up straight taketake
god damn charge of the [ __ ] goddamn
game here
so anyways uh which mummy
mother-in-law's birthday and it got
rained out like a month or two ago so we
finally reach
scheduled this thing we went on the more
these wine trips out here to Malibu
and they have these giant [ __ ] like
600 acre ranches out there because I
will always you know ever I'm flying by
and I always look over and see all that
[ __ ] that there's basically no place
to land you know I was kind of thinking
like wow it's amazing that it hasn't
been developed I guess because they're
all [ __ ] ranches eventually
eventually they'll get rid of all the
[ __ ] grapes and will turn into a
giant [ __ ] meadow I don't know what
this lecture call it apartment complexes
or whatever so anyway so we go up there
and first of all it's so up in the
[ __ ] Hills like the GPS isn't working
and it actually ends up taking us to
this [ __ ] parole board thing that's
in the middle there they got the barbed
wire transfer look like minimum security
thing that we went into like all right I
don't think this is the [ __ ] wine
place so we end up going back and they
have on the farm you know they have a
place where you just go get boozed you
know boozed up listen to some bands and
that type of [ __ ] and you know this
something about wine drinkers you just
don't want to be around them I don't
know it gives you a brutal [ __ ]
hangover I like a nice flat you know
it's going like [ __ ] what cessation
start talking about fava beans or
somebody's liver I look at nice glass
with the meal but that's about it
but anyway so they also have like a
safari up there we have like yaks we
have this [ __ ] giraffe they have
camels they had these emus they had all
this crazy [ __ ] you could go up and feed
him and all that type of stuff so we're
up there having a great time meeting
these [ __ ] yaks and zebras and stuff
and and of course you know they got
these giant bull like things and this is
[ __ ] jerk off with these one of these
guys you know that bought like the
top-of-the-line loafers you know but
they're loafers babies really this
[ __ ] you know it's the kind of [ __ ]
Ric Flair would buy as a joke right just
so we could hold him in some broke guy's
face and say that his shoes cost more
than the house but this guy was like
serious and he's wearing there's like
dirt on the ground obviously he's
walking around and so all of you know
I'm over feeding the [ __ ] yak and all
of a sudden I had
unmistakable sound of a bull hitting the
[ __ ] metal rail of a fence I don't
know why I know that sound I think it's
part of the [ __ ] caveman DNA that
still left in everybody that you you
know where you just interview everyone
like walk down the street and office and
dogs behind a fence in a growls and your
whole body just [ __ ] gets that tingle
and you come with like I'm telling you
you know if you started running right
then you probably could run as fast as
bo Jackson you know that's how fast Bo
Jackson could run just to gain four
yards he ran as fast as someone would
run if a saber-toothed tiger was [ __ ]
about ready to eat him you know that
first [ __ ] step anyways I heard that
sound immediately I just I was just I
was already being like alright I'm going
to get [ __ ] trampled or worst case
scenario this thing's going to hook
under my belt and my [ __ ] pants are
going to go down to my ankles as my junk
is flapping around like that poor
bastard everybody sees like that guys
like this over his [ __ ] there's no way
to laugh that off you ever seen that one
the bull [ __ ] gets in the guy's belt
loop tips them upside down and just it's
just thrashing him around the guy's
pants go all the way down to his ankles
and people went from being like oh my
god that's going to die to everybody
just sitting there laughing at this guy
and I you know he's thinking like oh my
god this thing's going to door my
[ __ ] dick right you know in you know
the chick that he finally got the
[ __ ] courage to get you know the
courage to ask up ask up ask out up out
over in whatever you want to take this
[ __ ] out right so he probably was
awkward so he's going like you know what
I'll do something amazing and then
that'll give her my I'll show you how
courageous I am right so he runs with
the [ __ ] bulls and right as she was
being like you know he kind of any seems
like he's fun all of a sudden he's
upside down and then there's his [ __ ]
little [ __ ] little smackle right
there's Jewish people say [ __ ]
flopping around and it was just over
that guy not only had to leave his
hometown his province he had to leave
the country he might have had to leave
the continent but now with [ __ ]
YouTube it's just you know and Here I am
talking about it
right sexist
genders have an easier time relocating
than that [ __ ] guy after that one so
anyways so I hear that sound and right
as I turn around I see the bull coming
off the fence and I see this guy in
loafers you know had run back away from
the fence right and what was funny was I
went over there and I fed the [ __ ]
bull and nothing happened came over
there
I had a relaxed energy I [ __ ] you know
I had my [ __ ] weight on my back foot
you know standing like a [ __ ] boxer
you know I wasn't standing there
flat-footed like a little do when that
[ __ ] thing comes I'm gonna fall on my
ass I was already anticipate like I am
NOT ending up in a [ __ ] YouTube video
I'm already a white guy and we I already
I am prone to walking up to animals like
they're dogs I don't know why white
people do that but I do that I see a
lion at the zoo and I want to go up and
give it a belly rub low [ __ ] degrees
right where are other groups of people
for some reason they they understand not
even for some reason what they're doing
is common sense whatever [ __ ] reason
white people we just want to go up you
know I don't know if it's [ __ ] stupid
generally speaking right so I'm like
what a [ __ ] idiot and you see the
guys got that looking at race a car I
know it's got hit in the face by [ __ ]
bullhorn right and surprisingly the
guides didn't say [ __ ] right and then
we're all going to get back on the
little stuff open thing safari truck and
I hear boom I hear it again in the same
fight look around again same [ __ ] guy
backpedaling in the stupid loafers and
they don't say a [ __ ] word to this
guy so I'm just like this guy is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right so we get on this
thing and I was driving over and now
we're going to go see this giraffe this
teenaged giraffe named Stanley the
coolest [ __ ] giraffe you're ever
going to meet it just was not afraid of
people whatsoever which of course is
dangerous the first thing I thought of
when I [ __ ] saw the giraffe was like
I remember seeing a giraffe on YouTube
kick a [ __ ] lioness this lioness went
to jump on the things back and it timed
it perfectly
okay like Andre Agassi's [ __ ] dead
dead [ __ ] shot he used to do write up
the [ __ ] is not the baseline write up
the [ __ ] whatever used to rip that
back hang out right up and you know he
always talked [ __ ] about made a lot of
money with that shot right that's what
the [ __ ] giraffe did but what does
leg kick the line and what are they well
how much the line weighed like six
hundred pounds dude he sent this [ __ ]
thing it looked like it was doing like
it was in the middle of doing a jumping
jack and it was just but it was just
like doing this
airborne cartwheel and it never came
down and this thing [ __ ] flipped
around like three times and it hit the
ground and it did not get up alright I
know I used this reference a lot but you
remember the last hit brett favre took
that's what this lioness looked like
from a giraffe I couldn't believe it I
jumped up when I saw it you know it was
like watching the nerd beat up the bully
all these guys were piling on and what
was funny when the other lion saw that
they were all like oh [ __ ] I didn't know
I didn't know the giraffe could do that
yeah it was like the Bruce Lee [ __ ]
was at the one-inch punch when he'd send
somebody flying across the room we get
it built so that's that's all I'm
thinking is I am not getting anywhere
near that thing's [ __ ] legs of course
they got like a 10-foot fence and then
you walk up the thing was 16 feet high
is a teenager right and you go all the
way up and all right at that level it's
just its head and you have feeding it
little pieces of banana and all that
[ __ ] with the skin they just cut it up
in sections and the way it would eat it
looked like an old man that took its
dentures out and it was adorable and you
know he [ __ ] pet the thing on its
head it was perfect right brain ways as
we're pulling up to go see this [ __ ] the
guide goes all right he goes now look
those camels over there he goes you got
to be careful with those things
he goes they're very aggressive you know
all they want is food but if you don't
have food they're going to you've got a
great chance that they're going to bite
you
because they're going to get it one way
or another that's just how they're wired
and their necks are longer than you
think so don't be you know turning your
back on them trying to get itself
because you're going to get bit and he
goes in as much as I say this you know
couple to three people a month get bit
right so he said this all right right
and I all I was thinking was Goodfellas
right and after all there yeah yeah
[ __ ] what did she do she makes a
[ __ ] phone call from the home phone
right exact same [ __ ] thing there was
these three women in front of us and for
whatever [ __ ] reason like the second
he gave that speech I was like you know
what [ __ ] those camels I'm not going
anywhere near him I didn't try to feed
him I knew I'm not [ __ ] going to feed
something when the tour guy goes we're
[ __ ] three people get bit a month I'm
just like you know what guess who's not
going to be one of those three old
freckles over here alright so we go
everybody pets the giraffes we look at
these [ __ ] emus which are the
creepiest goddamn animal ever I don't
know they do they have a look on that
[ __ ] face I can't even I can't trying
to describe the look it's like just
imagine if like you are in your backyard
and you were just drinking a glass of
lemonade and all of a sudden you saw the
ground moving and a person just came up
from under the ground just imagine how
dirty their face would be and as they
walk towards you to take a sip of
lemonade just imagine that look on their
face that's what it looked like I went
to be one of those things and it [ __ ]
came walking over like a zombie like I
don't know what it was and I got this
thing where they don't they can't like
just gently take [ __ ] they go they do
like [ __ ] pit viper left like your
[ __ ] head comes right at you I held
this [ __ ] out and the second that thing
locked eyes on me I [ __ ] just dropped
the carrot and left like there and so
over there stupid and the thing was too
dumb to [ __ ] look down crazy it was
like it had like I swear to God like
that description they have when people
are on the front lines in a [ __ ] war
like World War one
this thing look like I'd seen horror its
entire [ __ ] life and it's just like
do you know how but I just leave it here
on the top of the fence and you figure
it out so anyway so we're walking back
to the little safari truck and those
three [ __ ] legs where are they at
everybody where did it where do you
think that they're at you think they're
getting on the truck you know you think
they're getting ready to go enjoy glass
of [ __ ] wine at the winery no uh-uh
they're over by the [ __ ] camels and
they're [ __ ] getting really close but
they got character they're okay but
they're way in this thing's [ __ ]
wheelhouse okay and I'm just sitting
there going like at least mutter to me I
go near filmless because one of them is
going to get bit one of them's going to
get bit right so the cutest one of them
all right [ __ ] what does she do after
this guy says don't turn your back and
try to take it selfie what does this
[ __ ] woman do she turns her [ __ ]
back she's in this thing's [ __ ]
wheelhouse she was so close to the thing
it almost had to double back with its
[ __ ] neck it was what it did it
[ __ ] once it realized it didn't have
any more carrots it she didn't it
[ __ ] doubled back and [ __ ]
basically bit this woman right on her
boob her left boob she had a jacket on
and she doesn't like that and [ __ ]
stepped away fortunately it didn't clamp
down and it [ __ ] it had she had these
disgusting like just greens to like
grass stains and saliva because the
things [ __ ] eat grass all day and she
gets back to the thing and she's doing
that whole oh my god that thing just
like bit me in the boob right and the
tour guide funniest thing ever
he just looks at and he goes no I
[ __ ] told you
he dropped the f-bomb he uh [ __ ] told
you it's my favorite thing that I think
I've seen I can't remember that reminds
me of when I was a kid if I I was part
of the last generation the last tale
part of if you slipped on the ice it was
your [ __ ] fault
it wasn't the guy's fault who had the
storefront it's like yeah ice is
slippery stupid yeah maybe next time
you'll [ __ ] be a little more careful
and then somehow it became it became the
shop on his fault that you [ __ ] were
walking too recklessly on ice like it's
his ice it's not his ice it's made by
the Lord right that's like McDonald's
having to make salad they took [ __ ]
responsibility rather than it's like no
it's your fault you're fat you ordered
50 [ __ ] Big Macs you [ __ ] you know
we're a business if you order it we're
going to give it to you you [ __ ] dope
you know what do you want you do have to
go eat a whole [ __ ] gallon of ice
cream the [ __ ] is wrong with you they
somehow took the responsibility they
started making [ __ ] salad stupidest
thing I've ever seen in my life so
anyways yeah and that guy eat you say
huh [ __ ] told you dude it was like
needle off the record I couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
and they didn't say anything it was like
it was like watching Donald Trump in
that first debate when he was still
funny before it was like holy [ __ ] this
guy's this guy might run the country now
who can know he might speak for the
company might pretend to be running the
country that's the real deal that's why
you can't be too afraid of Donald Trump
because at the end of the dates but you
know come on people we all know you know
I'll tell you right now if I was [ __ ]
Isis those [ __ ] dopes trying to sneak
into this country and blow people up and
[ __ ] all those [ __ ] idiots got to do
is just get together their money and you
just [ __ ] put some money on Hillary
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump right
that's all you got to do and then you
buy a little bit of average
heisting time on all the major networks
and you'll never hear about them again
that's how people that's how those
[ __ ] you know genetically alter food
you never [ __ ] hear about it because
they got their [ __ ] money in
everybody's pockets and everybody shuts
the [ __ ] up so that's what I used to do
they should just do that and then they
could just walk into this country with
the goddamn bazooka on that back and no
one would say [ __ ] anyways so yeah
that's what it was like the first debate
with Donald Trump where he was just
literally saying he said this about
women you said that about women tonight
I said about I said that about Rosie
O'Donnell they're like no no he said it
about other women too and he just goes
yeah you know you're probably right
probably right that was it was over
she's like a guy I think that'd be a
fool because I [ __ ] told you no
sympathy no [ __ ] sympathy it was
perfect it's exactly it's exactly what I
think most people need you know look I'm
not saying that you shouldn't have
empathy I'm not saying that you
shouldn't have sympathy in that type of
[ __ ] all I'm saying is there there is a
time and a place for no sympathy and
that that was it that was it was it was
done perfectly you know I think she's
going to be a better person because of
it she couldn't even argue he's like I
[ __ ] told you and when you really
think about it it's like when she
because I think bit me in the boob it's
like it's like I just [ __ ] told you it
was going to do that like what do you
think he's going to say oh we did it all
I'm sorry did it do exactly what the
[ __ ] I said it was going to do and then
that was it and then the next thing we
did was we [ __ ] went over we checked
over all these original like [ __ ] air
streams and then we were drinking wine
and like that all happened like we got
on the tree like it bitter in the boob
he said well I [ __ ] told you and then
we would drink in wine outside and I was
just like this my name is [ __ ]
awesome that should be part of the tour
that was it weird am I making a bigger
deal about it and it was so [ __ ]
refreshing yeah [ __ ] you know that's
on you
alright here we go a Billy Belgium bill
big fan are you planning a trip to
Belgium in the [ __ ] huge yeah can't
wait to see you life on stage now you
came close live Li ve and right now I'm
still I'm sticking with that French by
the way i am doing duolingo i got 23
days in a row michael jordan 23 [ __ ]
days in a row and i'm just going to keep
[ __ ] doing this [ __ ] i try to get 200
points a day sometimes i don't bite so i
get at least 100 although Tuesday it
looks like I only got 10 I did one
lesson here I am for the week I got like
160 then I got 10 180 210 200 110 and
230 that ain't bad
hey Bill this isn't about you it's about
the [ __ ] question you're right you're
writing it I get distracted I get
distracted with a [ __ ] am i ah Jesus
Christ and there's another way I'm
trying to learn French I go to the
montreal canadiens website and I go
under the French side and I know
sacrilegious but I [ __ ] do it and I
you know what do they say something
learning the hard way the last times
like a the friend is something dearest
of di re I can kind of read it I still
can't [ __ ] speak it I stink at it but
at least I'm getting to the point where
I can kind of read you know at a decent
level I've been going on YouTube and
I've been watching these [ __ ] you
know they like kids shows I thought oh
god I'm gonna get put on a list but I'm
learning I'm learning I'm [ __ ] read it
weather just going like the cat the cat
says meow
you know meow cat meow oh look at the
dog they do it all in French right no
[ __ ] check it was all alright big fan
are you planning a trip to Belgium in
the future can't wait to see you life
alive on stage great brain great humour
love your show
absolutely 100% going to get there at
some point this year I am planning a
tour of Eastern Europe and then my usual
run through the whitest people of all
time from Finland all the way over to
Iceland and I'm planning to end in
Iceland and spend an extra couple of
days there at the Blue Lagoon spa and
you got to do it and you should go
during the winter when all the [ __ ]
tourists are not there you want to be
there when there's snow on the ground I
mean right now I don't know if the
Northern Lights are still we probably
missed it by now but like that's one
that's like a bucket listening for me I
want to go there see the [ __ ]
Northern Lights when I went there I felt
like I was on the top of the earth and
it was the bluest place I'd ever been to
in my life
the sky was so [ __ ] blue it was crazy
and telling he's right everybody always
flies past it but he goes right by it
just [ __ ] you got to go to it I got
to tell you when take a shower there you
got yo you are going to taste [ __ ]
salsa that's a little gross but other
than that fantastic okay so I will
definitely be there hopefully by the end
of the year our painting of Jesus
laughing dear Billy Christ my in-laws
have had this paint have had this
hanging in their house since I've known
them and I get a good chuckle every time
I see it hope you do too men at least
one artist depicts the guy is a jolly
man now I got to go back because I
copied and pasted it pasted it did it
copy and paste it oh yeah it doesn't
even look like Jesus I got a while we
got it we got to tweet that that photo
out what made him laugh like that
something is probably like hey you know
I bang to a hooker like you do I still
have a chance to get to heaven
ha ha ha you know you could rent
laughing like that you hang it on a
cross like me there Freck oh all right
I'll definitely
let the posted I'm sitting on my lower
back again how does this happen just lie
down the [ __ ] couch
alright girlfriends dysfunctional family
alright dear Billy Boy huge fan of
pockets thank you anyways I am a male in
his early 20s living in a small
one-bedroom apartment with my girlfriend
recently my girlfriend's mother has
received a new job position that's much
closer to us and she is currently in the
process of looking for a new place in
our area GJ I am all for my girlfriend
being able to be closer to her family
why why would you be all for that be all
for it if they're cool I'm saying right
now do not marry anybody who does not
have a cool [ __ ] family okay because
those [ __ ] are going to be in
your house you think you're going to
marry her and then yeah take it easy
that set that day you're going to
[ __ ] Walter out the door to your
wedding now they're going to be calling
your house they're going to be coming
over they're going to want to [ __ ]
play with your kids okay
those people are you are marrying into
the [ __ ] family so right now I think
what you're doing is you're trying to be
a modern man so you're just
automatically going like I'm all for it
I'm all for you expressing your opinions
and having your mother be right across
the [ __ ] Street listen I'm probably
projecting here like I said thank God
thank Christ
the lovely Nia has a wonderful family
thank God thank Christ because I know
people in that situation in that
situation like [ __ ] misery the misery
of the family like you know they retire
and then they just move to where you are
and then they just come over all the
[ __ ] time and they have no [ __ ]
clue how annoying they are and then if
the wife doesn't [ __ ] say anything
you got to step up off the [ __ ] [ __ ]
show all right recently my girlfriend's
above above I'm all for my girlfriend
being able to be closer to her
family as I enjoy their company as well
oh [ __ ] you know I didn't read that part
sorry but the whole moving situation is
starting to become a bit of a headache
and it's starting to impede on our own
lives yeah see you're young you're in
your early 20s okay here we go my
girlfriend's mother is currently in
between places and might stay with us
during the week however this is not the
worst of it my girlfriend has three
other siblings that her mother provides
care for two brothers and one sister her
oldest brother in particular is a bit of
a black sheep he is easily agitated by
the smallest requests like cleaning up
after himself or remembering to lock the
door he is careless when it comes to
using other people's belongings and does
not clean up after himself
well you know what that [ __ ] that he
can't say that
I would I would be a bit more forgiving
if he was younger than I am but he too
was in his early 20s like me now having
to deal with the family member like this
may not sound like an issue dude this is
this is this was making I'm breaking out
in hives reading this thing this is how
much of a [ __ ] issue this is uh
especially if your girlfriend does not
address what a douche a brother is
that's what you need okay that's the
keys to the castle okay if there's
someone in you know whatever if you're a
woman dating a guy right if he has come
with his sister's a [ __ ] and he won't
address it on any level I'm not saying
he literally has to drop the [ __ ] you
know the c-note there but you got you
got it you got a [ __ ] it you got to
address it okay
you got to [ __ ] address it alright so
anyways now having to deal with this
possible but do you remember like this
may not sound like an issue today but I
learned that my girlfriend's mother
asked to bring my girlfriend's brother
with her to stay with us for a few days
let's face it it'll probably be longer
than that after seeing firsthand how he
acts with other people especially his
family I want to say no and be done with
it
but I'm sure this will open up more
issues between myself and my girlfriend
mother and possibly her brother yes
it'll bring up great issues the fact
that her brother's a [ __ ] selfish
douche dude you are right now in the
beginning of creating your adult life so
when you feel no you say no all right
and if your girlfriend gets [ __ ]
pissed then [ __ ] her okay if she wants
to break up with you you know what you
did dude you just you just walked away
from what you know what you spent you
fast-forward you're fast-forwarding
through the [ __ ] nightmare and you're
getting to the inevitable end of the
[ __ ] relationship without you being
legally bonded to them without you
having kids that half [ __ ] look like
her and just remind you of them every
[ __ ] time you remind you or her every
time you see them this is what you have
to do you have to listen to your gut in
life you got will tell you you're saying
I don't want to do this but then what
happens is social politeness kicks in uh
you know it's only for a few days bah
bah bah bah I don't know hmm and you
[ __ ] all of that [ __ ] all of that I'm
not saying that you have to say it the
way I'm saying it but you have to have a
sit-down and just be like listen I don't
mind if your mother stay here but I'm
not comfortable with your brother
staying here and she says why it's my
brother be like because he's
inconsiderate and he's reckless with
personal belongings he forgets to lock
the door and all that and I don't think
he's a responsible person and just let
it sit there and if she has the [ __ ]
problem with it who gives us I don't do
not be disrespectful just feel like I
don't share your viewpoint and I live
here too and I'm sorry I'm saying no we
can't stay here
and then she'll have nothing to say
other than so you saying you can't say
here should I start repeating what
you're saying it'd be like that is what
I'm saying and then you let her huff and
you let her puff and do all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's going to do and you don't let
that [ __ ] douche step into the house
and let me have to thank you what are
you what do you have to lose here other
than your own happiness you got to put a
value on it anyways let me just continue
on here he says after seeing firsthand
how he acts with other people especially
his family I want to say no but I'm sure
this to open up more issues to myself my
girlfriend her mother and possibly her
brother as it is an issue
with my girlfriend and I have argued
about it in the past oh yes you've
already done it yeah dude all right
you're already knocked down they already
kicked in the door walk in what would
you do in this situation I think I've
already said it and is there any sort of
advice you can give me if a brother does
come to stay for a few days how should I
treat him knowing he'd probably just get
agitated with me telling him to clean up
after himself thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself dude this is the deal dude this
isn't this is non-negotiable this is non
[ __ ] negotiable okay this is your
life all right and he's a [ __ ] douche
and listen man if your girlfriend can't
see what a [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is
do can you imagine if your brother was
like this and it made your girlfriend
feel uncomfortable would your brother
being staying with you he makes me
uncomfortable oh no he's weird you're
the pickup he smells my me undies
whatever the [ __ ] he's doing you'd be
like all that fit you can't you can't be
here you know wait what was it cuz
you're a jerk-off all right there's a
super right down the street
good luck to you you know I got to tell
you this this this might be this might
be the old right there fret for your
[ __ ] relationship okay you might have
to throw down the gauntlet all right I
gotta tell you dude if this if this
[ __ ] [ __ ] is already making you
this [ __ ] miserable okay just the
idea of him staying with you for a
couple to three days all right
are you really gonna marry this woman
you gonna marry into that with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] show and they'll die in
there you made me very [ __ ] tea and
[ __ ] that until he goes out and he [ __ ]
his whole [ __ ] life up or you know
and what happens to you do you I'm
assuming you're planning on being
successful in life right which means
you're going to go make a big bag of
loot and get yourself a whip right sorry
now you can have a nice car you have a
nice house you know if you
before wiping it have all that type of
[ __ ] you know it you know what [ __ ] do
can't think like well how come I don't
have that it's like well because you
didn't work for it's stupid and they're
not going to think that and they are
going to want to come around and they're
going to want [ __ ] handouts and if
she in if that [ __ ] jerk-off knows
that his sister is a big softy she's
going to use her to get to you and all
the [ __ ] that you [ __ ] work for okay
I'm painting a very bleak scenario here
but dude you just you say no he can't
stay here you know and if it really
comes down to she said listen I don't
like the guy okay
and I don't think it's I just think it's
how he's wired because you turned out
great you guys both had the same [ __ ]
parents I don't know what happened to
that guy but he's a [ __ ] I don't say
[ __ ] that guy is just like I don't
want him in my I don't want him here
your mother can say Plus that it's only
a one-bedroom apartment you know so
we're going to be on top of each other
and I can't deal with that guy when I
met your mother's house forget about in
our one-bedroom apartment I don't want
that guy here I don't want to balls
dangling in our [ __ ] commode I don't
want his pubes in my shower I don't want
his hands in my son the fridge I still
want to me I want in here you know
what's funny I don't even know this guy
and I [ __ ] hate him there's no
[ __ ] way dude please can you please
do this for yourself and this is a great
exercise to have you know for both men
and women you can flip this around like
learning how to stand up to the person
that you with you got to learn how to do
that and sometimes you just have that
you gotta have a fight you just have to
have a fight and and there is a freedom
to not giving a [ __ ] in a good way what
people think about you I mean give the
[ __ ] if some pieces so selfish [ __ ]
doesn't like you what the [ __ ] do you
care
I had my oh jeez I would have you just
openly I don't like you yes you I don't
like you I think you're a piece of
garbage and then we looked at his
girlfriend you look at your girlfriend
or his sister you just fit yes don't
worry I already told her
ah
sir please don't let him stay in your
place and please right right in and
please tell me please tell me what
happened
I don't know why but I live for moments
like this in life you know as much as I
meant like making people laugh and that
type of thing I get even more enjoyment
telling pieces of [ __ ] no it's one of
the great things and just to look on the
[ __ ] face because the reason why a
lot of pieces of [ __ ] are pieces of [ __ ]
because people politely maneuver around
them and when you can get that [ __ ]
admit right in their face you know put
your hand right in their forehead that's
about far enough there Sparky uh just
it's one of the great failings in life I
think that's why God made douchebags
just so you know someone like yourself
can have that feeling I'm really coming
up arrogant here I'm probably the
douchebag - anyways alright fiancees
wedding plans a dad Billy blue band blue
bland the [ __ ] is that first let me say
I can't see I can't wait to see you in
Orlando on May 7th I don't know why I
haven't seen you perform live yet but
you are my you are the last of my top
ten comedians to see before I die oh
Jesus there's way more than you should
see than that but I am very flattered
that I am one of the ten okay so he says
I've been engaged for three years now
alright dumper you don't want to marry
her do I really need to read the rest of
this the [ __ ] is engaged for three years
he said and me and my lady are in the
first steps of finally planning our
wedding I am simple animal and am okay
with something small and would rather
save money for our honeymoon and down
payment on the house and let me guess
she wants to spend a ton of [ __ ]
money
my fiance wants a destination themed
wedding I'm not opposed to compromise
and have a destination wedding but she
wants to theme to be the little mermaid
in Hawaii she's adamant about this and
has these horrible outfits picked out
for the whole wedding party too
we're including myself as Neptune I
don't believe this
I'm calling [ __ ] but you know what
as always I'll read it like it's true
I'm 37 as she was 28 if that matters I
sincerely love her but she won't let
this go and I absolutely refuse to go
through with that I don't want to lose
her in my life but I've tried everything
I can think of to talk her out of it and
honestly it's a deal breaker for me
please tell me your thoughts and if you
have any advice I'd be very grateful
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all right
look this isn't a joke question you've
been engaged for three [ __ ] years
okay that's weird I think that's
something going on there and you know
you're you're a little bit country she's
a little bit rock and roll forever that
the old [ __ ] Donny and Marie show
usually sometimes opposites you know you
know she's dead party you she completes
you I don't think she said I just this
is a [ __ ] show if this is true you are
you're a do you understand that when you
went inevitably get divorced from this
[ __ ] woman that you're going to get
no sympathy from anybody there's a
little first bee oh my god a divorce I
heard you know other than losing a loved
one that's the most stressful thing ever
but when you tell the story that you
dressed like Neptune at your own [ __ ]
wedding and right then everything now
you know I [ __ ] told you yeah dude
you walk away from it you're 37 you fine
you'll meet somebody else okay you get
on you have a biological clock just one
of the great things about being a dude
you know but it all balances out because
we died eight years before them you know
so they get the little little bit you
know live a little bit longer sit in
that coffee house you know eatin those
[ __ ] weird chocolates should oh this
is somebody else's I'm sorry I thought
that's how he signed up um yeah I would
walk away from this whole [ __ ] thing
how many more red flags need to be shook
in your face you just walk away from the
whole [ __ ] thing but you can't no my
god dude what kind of [ __ ] issues
does she have that she wants to have a
little yeah oh my god she went those
women that has that
goo gaga creepy ass [ __ ] voice she
talks like she's [ __ ] sticks
oh god that gives you the [ __ ] chills
can you be a [ __ ] adult over here
what do we mean what if you wanted a
scooby Doo theme [ __ ] wedding right
you wanted her to dress like [ __ ]
that with the Janeane Garofalo redheaded
one you know and her sister to dress
like Daphne and you were going to be
[ __ ] Shaggy the best man was going to
dress like Fred with that scarf around
his [ __ ] I don't like them I don't
believe that question I just don't okay
and if you [ __ ] marry her you deserve
it you know and when you come crying up
to me I'm going to steal from that
[ __ ] toy ass like I told you all
right Squatch a billy bird legs that's
[ __ ] hilarious accent listen if you
talk about the way you work out of the
podcast and I got a chime in do some
[ __ ] squats do squats are not a leg
exercise they are a compound full body
movement this is already making me tired
put a couple hundred pounds on your back
just push your legs and watch while your
frail freckled spine gets twisted like a
pretzel well why would I want to do that
squats and deadlift which I recommend to
need you to engage damn near every
muscle in your body if you want to put
on some real muscle density stop being
such a cowardly little cop and learn to
squat and deadlift dude I don't want to
walk around all bulked up you know start
wearing tank tops I'm not trying to do
that Jesus Christ he said I recommend
watching Eddie CoA and apostrophe s
squat and deadlift videos from super
training on YouTube to start dude I'm
not trying to get into the NFL then
watch the rest of their content and
learn what the [ __ ] you're doing I wrote
some stuff about my experience with
adding squats and deadlifts to my
routine you can read it or not just lift
some heavy [ __ ] stop being a [ __ ] and
go [ __ ] yourself alright I like the way
this man speaks gets right to it he's
very direct my experience when I was
younger I used
I used to be a mirror muscles guys
mirror muscle guy to [ __ ] you talking
about dude I got a pegboard I got those
atomic [ __ ] I'm doing all I'm trying
to do like half what American Ninja
Warrior [ __ ] thing I'm building that
in my garage alright you with your
[ __ ] Schwarzenegger workout from 1978
stop acting like you're in the future
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was decent you know you came in you
were talking a little bit fresh you need
to [ __ ] stand down a little bit here
then I got older and I started working
in a Chocolate Factory
everything seems like a live is you
worked in a chunk were you in a [ __ ]
tree making cookies amazingly doing
curls and benching 135 after spending
the day sitting at my desk shoveling
free chocolate in my face did not
nothing to stop my belly from growing
well yeah well neither would doing
squats okay if you don't [ __ ] eat
anything else but cookies anyways he
goes now I squat bench and deadlift like
a power lifter and I'm stronger and more
jacked than I have ever been yeah and
you stop eating chocolate not only do I
actually have legs now but my chest arms
and back traps everything are bigger
than ever I just I can't recommend the
videos from super training enough
alright I'll check it out the guys are
hilarious strongest [ __ ] and there there
is tons of great info on there anyways I
appreciate the podcast best of luck with
the new home gym and again go [ __ ]
yourself alright cool I will definitely
check that out thank you so much for
that information once again for people
at home Edie it's ezzio a and apostrophe
s for some reason I don't it looks like
it's missing something but anyways it's
called super training so if you spell
the name kind of like that it ought to
come up in your your google search there
okay about driving and diving into caves
hey Bill you were talking about divers
with those caves here's a documentary of
Finnish guys who legally illegally who
go illegally to their dead friends
bodies what
from their last trip I think it was made
illegal to go there after they died
because it was too dangerous to go to
those caves but they went anyway and
made a movie about it come to Finland
soon and go [ __ ] yourself why don't they
retrieve the bodies is everybody lying
to me this week why can't you be honest
all right the last one here girlfriend
is good friends with dudes she met on
tinder hey Billy read Berk Bork kind of
I guess is supposed to like Ray Bourque
red dork so recently I was talking with
my girlfriend about one of her guy
friends the two of them seemed pretty
close he did a photo shoot for a t-shirt
company
she's starting in and she even said
we're like the same person yeah dude
it's over it's over
she hasn't blown him yet she's gonna
walk away something she said something
she has said to me as we're talking she
reveals that she met this dude off of
the dating and actually just about
[ __ ] app tinder before dude you wrote
it so bad before she we got together I'm
just going to read the hell you wrote it
I tried to play it cool let her talk
about him and just brush it off as
whatever dude this is the brainwashing
of the American male now where
everything is if you even question a
woman it's like wait was that date rape
so you just ignore all your [ __ ]
instincts here I tried to play it cool
yeah her douchebag brother who totally
inconsiderate wants to stay here you
know
I'm all for that you're not all for that
your soul is screaming nope you're
playing it cool because you're not cool
with it yeah why don't you go hang out
with some [ __ ] buddy you met on tinder
and see how she [ __ ] likes it right
anyway well the two of them text quite a
lot and the other night she received
something I think from him and she
laughed now I am ordinarily not a nosy
type but the situation is weird so I
asked what's funny she flipped she said
I'm being too nosy and trying to pry
into her personal life oh my god and
then did you give her a sidekick right
out of the [ __ ] bed
he goes I mean she really flipped his
[ __ ] about it she claims I'm being
paranoid and that they are just friend I
don't know Billy if they [ __ ] what's
to say they won't dude what do you mean
you don't know he finishes it with am I
being paranoid should I not give a [ __ ]
or should I kick this chick to the curb
dude
punt her to the curb right in the feet
of her [ __ ] lying pants yeah yeah and
I would just say why are you breaking up
I go because you because the guy on
tinder completes you go get with him oh
my god you're being paranoid no I'm not
you guys are [ __ ] in my heart our
hearts you guys are [ __ ] and if
you're not you're gonna and to be honest
with you you probably should be you
[ __ ] laying in bed with me giggling
about his goddamn texts just go over
there and suck his dick already there
give me my keys that's it [ __ ] over
all right that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to you
Thursday